desde hace más de 50 años la familia de
domenico carbone cultiva trigo en este
terreno de 70 hectáreas en la poule ya
la principal región italiana productora
de cereales un cultivo cuyos costos se
han disparado desde el inicio de la
guerra en ucrania el costo de
fertilizantes el precio de los
fertilizantes se ha triplicado porque la
mayor parte de los fertilizantes que
usamos aquí en italia vienen de los
países en guerra conflicto
esta mañana con un sindicato agrícola
domenico analiza un posible aumento de
su superficie de cultivo con horno y un
giorno que la región quiere cultivar
cien mil hectáreas suplementarias de
trigo para prevenir la escasez de
cereales debido al bloqueo de las
importaciones de rusia y ucrania si
producimos más trigo aquí en italia
podríamos liberarnos de la dependencia
de otros países hay que cultivar más
aquí se trata de una estrategia nacional
que busca la autosuficiencia y la
soberanía alimentaria soberanía
alimentaria un objetivo ambicioso
actualmente y está le importa más del 30
por ciento del trigo que consume en
forma de pan galletas
el plato nacional los productores de
pasta que usan trigo italiano también se
ven afectados como esta empresa familiar
de pasta artesanal como ya no llevan
cereales de ucrania los productores que
usaban esas harinas ahora todos buscan
harinas italianas y el mercado interno
no da abasto para cubrir toda esta
demanda
haciendo una venta al detalle nos vemos
obligados a trasladar parte de los
aumentos en el precio final al
consumidor y paralelamente reducir
nuestros márgenes de ganancia el
gobierno espera en los próximos meses
aumentar las importaciones de cereales
de países como canadá o grecia para
evitar que estalle una crisis
alimentaria en italia